bonsoir fabrice di vizio merci d'être
avec nous la responsabilité donc de
jérôme salle au monde sur la pénurie de
masques pointé du doigt par les
sénateurs c'est désormais jérôme salomon
qui va cristalliser une faute une
responsabilité dans la gestion de cette
crise et en particulier la gestion des
masques je sais pas si j'ai repoussé le
monde va cristalliser une responsabilité
mais jérôme seulement à une
responsabilité et jérôme seulement à 2
responsabilité d'avoir fait pression sur
santé publique france et d'avoir menti
devant la commission d'enquêté
sénatoriale en excipant d'un rapport
qu'il savait être inexact puisque c'est
lui qui l'avait fait changer c'est à
dire que à un moment vous avez affaire à
quelqu'un qui de bout en bout
finalement à vraiment jouer un rôle
catastrophique dans cette crise et si on
en est là
nul doute que c'est en grande partie à
cause de lui quel est le pire pour vous
mettre division vous venez dire la
responsabilité dans la gestion des
stocks et d'une certaine manière la
dissimulation le mensonge quel est le
pire pour l'avocat de vous être juriste
que vous êtes le juriste que je suis a
envoyé aujourd'hui deux courriers l'un
au juge d'instruction en charge du
dossier
le deuxième à la commission
d'instruction de la cour de shiso
république en demandant à ce que
monsieur soit lhomond soient auditionnés
et au juge d'instruction en ajoutant que
la question de sa mise en examen pour
faux témoignage doit se poser ça c'est
ça c'est le juriste
le juriste il fait du droit et le droit
ici nécessite que l'on sache ce qui
s'est exactement passé et comment
qualifiés pénalement
cette pression exercée sur santé
publique france et pourquoi santé
publique france à accepter cette
pression tandis que de l'autre et bien
mentir devant une commission d'enquêté
sénatoriale
ça constitue encore une infraction dans
ce pays et donc le plus grave dans tout
ça c'est quoi
eh ben le plus grave je vais vous dire
ce que c'est que le plus grand le plus
grave c'est clair cinquante mille morts
voilà ce que c'est que le plus grand le
plus grave c'est que pendant que ces
gens font une espèce d'entre eux soient
littéraires lorsque on joue sur les mots
on joue sur les concepts est bien la
vérité c'est qu'ils avaient pas de
masquer la vérité c'est que les
soignants sont allés au front et son
bord la vérité c'était populations n'ont
pas pu être protégées
c'est ça qui est le plus grave alors ce
qui est étonnant on l'a vu dans le
reportage de bassem chemise c'est
finalement jérôme seulement étaient
assez lucide il avait alerté le candidat
macron sur une éventuelle pandémie que
la france n'était pas prête il est
devenu ensuite directeur général de la
santé et là il ya eu cette attitude
semble-t-il qu'est ce que ça dit du
système
sadi de ce système je l'employé un mot
dur qu'il est pourri jusqu'à la moelle
donc ce système il est gangréné ça
prouve que la politique a raison de tout
quand je vous dis depuis le premier jour
que tout est politique
dans cette crise que tout à été
communication dans cette crise c'est ça
que je voulais dire et j'en ai bien la
preuve encore aujourd'hui j'étais un
prophète eut désole un jeudi au musée de
la province et la prophétie qui a piqué
facile puisque tout le monde le sait
mais quand je vous dis que la
problématique de ce pays c'est que la
politique gangrène tout c'est c'est la
manifestation tangible
il a conscience du danger il a
conscience de jouer avec la vie des gens
mais à un moment la raison politique
la raison d'économie politique est bien
à raison de tout précisément
et j'ajoute que vous me demandiez ce
qu'est le plus grave et après je dois
faire confiance là à l'homme que je vois
là sur vos images pour me vendre un
vaccin
je dois faire confiance à celui ci là
pour venir me vacciner et m'expliquer
les yeux dans les yeux que je ne crains
rien lorsqu'il me vaccine mais de qui
est ce qu'on se moque bien sûr que j'ai
pas confiance en lui bien sûr que
n'importe quel citoyen un tout petit peu
éveillées ne pourrait plus jamais avoir
confiance en jérôme salomon et que dès
lors la seule question qui se pose c'est
est-ce que jérôme seulement va être
couvert par son ministre de tutelle
ou est-ce que jérôme seulement va être
chaud
chez par sony style m division je parle
sous votre contrôle mais le rapport dit
que jérôme simplement était en réalité
informé de la situation des stocks en
2018 il a pourtant décidé de ne pas
reconstituer ses stocks et surtout de ne
pas en informer la ministre de tutelle à
l'époque agnès buzyn ensuite remplacé
par olivier ferrand est ce que d'une
certaine manière ça des douanes
agnès buzyn que ma connaissance vous
poursuivez aussi pour sa gestion de la
crise tout comme olivier vert alors à us
buzet avait dit quelque chose si vous
vous souvenez avait dit ces choses là ne
remonte pas au ministre en parlant de
des stocks de masques en fait entre
autres enfin les stocks de produits en
général et on voit qu'elle avait raison
finalement ça ne remonte pas au ministre
alors ça veut dire que jérôme salomon
quand je vous disais également que ce
pays est administrée n'est pas gouvernée
vous en avez encore la preuve manifeste
tous les maux de ce système sont
cristallisés dans la personne de jérôme
salomon géraud sono motta
l'administrateur et on a laissé ce pays
être administrés et pas de gouverner ça
des douanes le ministre m'a donc ça le
dédouane pas parce que le patron de
jérôme salle mancelle ministre celui qui
est nommé à la fonction de gouvernement
et qui assurent le gouvernement de la
cité en particulier en matière de santé
c'est le ministre jérôme salomon
pardonnez moi de le dire comme ça c'est
un second couteau
sauf que c'est un second couteau
qu'après la place du ministre il est
calife à la place du calife
et on l'a laissé faire aujourd'hui quels
sont les enseignements à tirer
rapidement de cette affaire et que doit
devenir jérôme salomon qu'un risque
at-il jérôme salomon ce qu'il doit
devenir je ne sais pas ce qu'il doit
faire c'est démissionner si jérôme
salomon reste aujourd'hui directeur
général de la santé ça veut donc dire
concrètement que l'on peut mentir et une
commission denquête on peut mettre les
populations en danger
on peut administrer dans le dos d'un
ministre et ce sans aucune conséquence
est bien la seule conséquence que ça
aura si jérôme salomon reste en poste
c'est que les français aient bien
n'auront plus confiance dans le
gouvernement et à une crise a ajouté
elle succédera une crise politique et
institutionnelle inégalée dans
l'histoire de la république
merci beaucoup fabrice di vizio avocat
en droit de la santé publique d'avoir
été avec nous en direct sur rt france